hunderttausende menschen flüchten
tagtäglich aus der ukraine vor krieg und
zerstörung
ungefähr zehn bis zwölftausend menschen
erreichen nach tagen der flucht die
grenze zwischen polen und deutschland
die bundespolizei ist von beginn an von
kriegsbeginn an also seit dem 24 februar
auf diese fluchtbewegung eingestellt
leider fehlt es bis heute an politischen
entscheidungen ob die bundespolizei
flächendeckend an der polnischen und
tschechischen grenze kontrollstellen
betreiben darf oder nicht mein appell an
die bundesregierung auch von hier noch
mal lasst uns endlich unseren job machen
die bundespolizei kann dass es ist eine
kernaufgabe die auch in unserer
verfassung niedergeschrieben ist das
thema grenzschutz und ich bitte noch
einmal herzlich darum um ordnung in
diese flüchtlingsströme zu bekommen
lasst die bundespolizei dort an der
grenze kontrollieren
wird könnten diese kontrollen aussehen
machen kann also die bundespolizei ist
sowohl technisch als auch personell so
ausgestattet dass innerhalb kürzester
zeit an den grenzübergängen an den
autobahnen an den bundesstraßen
gebäude errichtet werden könnten
container aufgestellt werden könnten
gemeinsam mit dem thw beheizte zelte
caterer rotes kreuz test spuren für für
für corona infektion selbst impfstraßen
könnten dort errichtet werden die
menschen hätten dort eine anlaufstelle
direkt an der grenze oder auf den
bahnhöfen in deutschland und könnten
dort professionell behördlich erfasst
werden und dann auch unter staatlicher
aufsicht weiter verteilt werden ohne
jetzt gefahr laufen zu müssen in die
hände privater
helfer zu geraten die ja auch hier in
berlin auf dem hauptbahnhof hauptbahnhof
ihre ehre schildchen hoch halten und
vielleicht was ganz anderes im schilde
führen als tatsächlich helfen zu wollen
das ist der status wie es sein könnte
wie sie es gerne machen würden auch ein
blick auf den grenzschutz mit blick auf
die kontrollen
aktuell betreibt die bundespolizei
sieben sogenannte bearbeitung straße das
sind meistens gebäude lagerhallen
leerstehende lagerhallen die wir so
umgebaut haben dass wir dort menschen
teilweise mit einer kapazität von bis zu
650 im durchlauf sozusagen unterbringen
könnten für die registrierung leider ist
es so dass wir derzeit am beispiel
frankfurt oder nur die ankommenden züge
genauer beleuchten und die menschen dort
aus den aus den zügen letztendlich in
diesem in diese einrichtung bringen
können was uns nur sehr sehr sehr
oberflächlich gelingt ist die
bestreifung der grenze also auch die die
nachschau an den grenzübergangsstellen
an den autobahn an den bundesstraßen und
auch an den kreisstraßen die von polen
nach deutschland führen das verzerrt
natürlich das bild und erschwert den
kommunen und den ländern dann
logischerweise auch die die erfassung
also ich sage ja immer wir wollen ja um
gottes willen niemanden an dieser grenze
zurückweisen das sind menschen die
wirklich schwer traumatisiert
kriegsflüchtlinge in unmittelbarer nähe
nach europa kommen aber wir müssen doch
wissen wer in unser land kommt und es
ist auch nicht auszuschließen dass sich
unter diese ströme auch personen mission
die eben nicht
kriegsflüchtlinge sind sondern was ganz
anderes im schilde führen und wir laufen
gefahr
die kontrolle nicht nur zu verlieren wir
haben sie seit 2015 in dem fall sowieso
nicht mehr aber wir laufen nicht gefahr
dass zu einem großen sicherheitsrisiko
in deutschland werden zu lassen ich
würde es ganz gerne mal diese diesen
misstrauens verdacht ausräumen wollen
der da immer mit im spiel ist wer
kontrolliert der ist auch an abwehr nur
interessiert oder tritt den migranten
mit misstrauen entgegen es geht
natürlich auch darum zu wissen wer
braucht besondere hilfe wer kann wohin
verteilt werden wer war vorhin hier und
ist demnächst in kaiserslautern wie
viele kinder muss man beschulen wer
braucht psychologische unterstützung die
polen machen das mustergültig an ihrer
grenze und registrieren auch diejenigen
die leute abholen von dort so dass man
eigentlich genau weiß wer wo sein müsste
das hat nichts mit überwachungsstaat zu
tun das ist glaube ich auch für die
soziale betreuung eigentlich ganz
hilfreich wenn man das nachvollziehen
kann oder sehen sie das anders kann ja
mal sagen wie wir das in berlin machen
wir konnten ja noch nicht warten das ist
ein perfektes system bundesweit gibt
sondern die menschen waren da und wir
mussten handeln und wir hatten null
vorlauf also am donnerstag begann der
krieg am freitag habe ich entschieden wo
wir sie aufnehmen und am samstag waren
die ersten da und von da an gab es in
karlstadt für ehrenamtlichen verwaltungs
mitarbeitende bei uns ist es jetzt so
wir haben unter zum einen erst mal jede
nacht sicherstellen müssen dass die
menschen einfach ein dach über den kopf
bekommen und was zu essen und das ist
die übrigens ein bisschen medizinische
notversorgung und die notfälle nehmen
deutlich zu und was wir jetzt plan ist
am ehemaligen flughafen tegel ein
ankunft zentrum wo alle menschen die in
berlin ankommt mit bussen hingefahren
werden wo dann und in einem
zusammenspiel von ehrenamtlichen
helfenden hilfsorganisation
verwaltungsmitarbeitern bis hin zur
bundespolizei das lf arbeitet mit der
bisschen bundeswehr bundeswehr es mit
dem einsatz und in das lf bei uns das
landesamt arbeitet mit der polizei
zusammen also in diesem zusammenspiel
ehrenamtliche aktivisten über verwaltung
bis hin zur bundeswehr findet dort eine
augen name reingehen machen sie dann
nicht genau das worum eigentlich hat es
heute abend bittet sie als politik
reißen es an sich wo er sagt hertha sagt
die bundespolizei könnte ist doch jetzt
schon regeln und zu aber ich bin aber
ich bin also erstmal die leute waren in
berlin und ich muss mich um sie kümmern
und ich sehe in der befehlskette nicht
über den tag und der bundespolizei keine
anweisung geben ich kann nur mit viel
sozusagen einsatz in berlin ins system
machen wie wir damit umgehen mit den
menschen die in berlin sondern ich finde
das was wir für tegel entwickelt haben
ist eine gute sache man muss also ich
finde auch immer dafür dass es ein
system gibt wo ehrenamtliche auch mit
integriert werden weil es gibt in der
bevölkerung eine enorme
hilfsbereitschaft die ist glaube ich
auch sehr sehr wichtig auch dass man die
welle der solidarität weiter trägt und
es ist den menschen noch ein bedürfnis
sich da einzubringen und gesagt wir
machen das so dass wir als allererstes
voran schalten wollen die bundesweite
verteilung und die die in berlin bleiben
die bekommen eine registrierung da gibt
es einen tegel eine erste unterkunft
protest und es braucht ja auch immer
medizinischen check möglichst es nach am
besten das impfzentrum nebenan dass man
dann vielleicht nicht in der ersten
nacht wenn die menschen nach einer
dramatischen flucht sind kann jetzt
nicht gleich mit der impfung kommen aber
am zweiten und dritten tag kann man das
machen und dann gibt es auch ein paar
hinweise weil es an der gewerkschaft was
man hier für arbeitsrecht hat dass man
da nicht irgendwie leuten in die hände
fällt die die im not jetzt ausnutzen und
das alles wird dann dort mit organisiert
das kann man bestimmt auch anders machen
hat bundesweit verteilt an der grenze
ich bin jetzt in berlin mit einer
situation konfrontiert gewesen und uns
war es wichtig im zusammenspiel aller
akteure da zum einen was ordnungsgemäße
auf die bahn zu setzen aber auch muss
ich sagen zuallererst zu schauen das
sind menschen die am schreckliches
hinter sich und da müssen ein paar dinge
geklärt werden für die bett essen
medizinische versorgung und ich
beobachte seit einigen tagen dass die
zahl der menschen die schwer
pflegebedürftig sind der am ganze busse
voll von blinden weil die in der blinden
einrichtungen sind wären ganze
waisenhäuser ein jüdisches weißen haus
mit 120 kindern was gekommen ist also
immer auch gruppen für die man dann noch
mal eine ganz spezielle unterkunft und
entsprechende unterstützung braucht also
mit vorstehe womit das sie sich mit der
sicherheitsfrage beschäftigen ich musste
mich zum beispiel mit fragen
beschäftigen wie da kommen er 100
ukrainische gehörlose das heißt man
braucht ein gebärdendolmetscher er muss
aber behördensprache ukrainisch und
deutsch sind noch mal unterschiedlich
das heißt da brauchst du noch mal zwei
die die sprache können das sind so
probleme mit dem wir uns auch noch
beschäftigen also und sie haben es jetzt
ja gerade gesagt ich beleuchte natürlich
die sich
genau aber das ist ja eigentlich nicht
ihr job die sicherheitsaspekte als
berliner sind achtzigern
werden die bundespolizei das schon hätte
machen können
wenn nämlich unsere bundesregierung die
grenzen zu polen und der tschechischen
republik notifiziert hatte wir wären wie
gesagt in der lage gewesen innerhalb
kürzester zeit sowohl materiell als auch
personell diese aufgabe zu übernehmen
nicht nur an den grenzen sondern auch an
den bahnhöfen wenn ich überlege dass ein
zug voll mit mitmenschen hier in berlin
auf dem hauptbahnhof einfährt und nicht
einmal das gleis der bahnsteig separiert
die türen gehen auf die menschen steigen
aus in einer völlig fremden stadt völlig
traumatisiert die wissen überhaupt gar
nicht wo sie hin sollen jetzt können sie
natürlich sagen ja da sind freiwillige
helfer vor ort
wo es was zu essen auch vermeiden und
bin weiter fort
wir müssen jetzt ihr engagement polizei
aufgehoben hatte
na ja also ich habe immer die polizei am
limit also so viele kräfte wie wir in
berlin im einsatz an wenn sie das alles
die bundespolizei machen will
das vorhaben plädiert frau kipping ich
bin gar nicht dagegen patzte bestimmt
punkte wo wir politisch echten dissenz
haben jetzt will ich auch in dieser
situation was ja so dass meine
sozialabteilung ein krisenstab mit der
bundespolizei kooperiert hat weil wir
hatten flugblätter wo auf ukrainisch
draufstand wo die leute hinkommen sollen
die haben wir natürlich als allererstes
am bundes bundespolizei und bahn
geschickt dass die die im zug verteilt
denn die einzigen von denen wir dann
irgendwann mal zahlen hatten wie die
züge voll sinn war entweder deutsche
bahn oder die die bundespolizei und wir
mussten jede nacht mit einer total
flexiblen zahl plan wie viele menschen
kommen irgendwann hatte man ein
erfahrungswert wenn ein zug mit 1000
menschen ankommt so und so viel gehen zu
privaten um so und so viel muss man sich
dann sofort kümmern also wir haben hier
echt also wir mussten das ja ausbaden
dass die zahlen nämlich so etwas sage ja
aber das ist doch chaotisch es ist doch
chaotisch man kann doch man kann doch
verdammt noch mal von einem rechtsstaat
verlangen dass das geordnet passiert und
jetzt sind wir schon im 22 tag des krieg
ist und der ankommenden menschen aus
diesen krieg und tatsächlich unternommen
also also es tut mir leid das sagen zu
müssen ich empfinde das nicht so dass
der staat jemals die kontrolle über
diese lage sicherheitspolitische lage
hat eine abschließende frage an sehr
tiger zu ihrer these der soziologe
reigen aus hat gesagt dass es sein kann
dass der nächsten zwei wochen dann würde
ich jetzt nicht falsch sind ihre zwei
millionen menschen zum größten teil nach
österreich und deutschland kommen zwei
millionen ist das möglich denkbar ist
dass bei uns hat es ja gerade
beschrieben denn wenn der beschuss aus
kiew noch weitergeht und und und
irgendwo müssen die menschen dann ja hin
und wenn sven die luft in der ukraine
noch dünner wird und die und die
russische armee dort auch nur noch mehr
land gewinne zu verzeichnen haben da
selbstverständlich das ist nicht
utopisch